this notion that quality is given up
when you do a quantity of creative is a
huge misnomer and something that I think
would really benefit the industry and
most of all the brands you got your
prospectus tell me yes just had a very
quick briefing yeah
Harriet but I gather you've got a little
bit of a different take on the market a
little bit of a different take yes I
think you know we started a company 10
years ago I is an individual through my
content and things that nature have been
quite loud but as an agency we've been
incredibly quiet hence why I think we're
kind of ready to get a little louder
hence why we made the amazing addition
of Harriet super deliberate stupid to
Liberty Clause yes and what was the next
other than that I think we're disrupting
you know the longer people underestimate
you or don't even know you exist tends
to have value
I also yeah I also was coming from the
outside I was coming from Silicon invent
valley investing and and wine ecommerce
so I came from a very different
background I am yes in 1996 I launched
one of the first e-commerce wine
businesses in America so that was my
first career being a marketer for my
family's liquor business and launching
this big e-commerce business was really
how I learned my craft of media and
creative and things of that nature and
so what what made you decide to leave
wine I mean personally I just
start with the wine you know what mate
it was a family it was a family business
okay and my I you know I got to I got
into my early in mid-30s I invested in
Facebook and Twitter and Tumblr which
obviously changed the course of my
career the world the world opened up for
me a little bit and I started realizing
that I was a marketer that I was a
marketer that happened to run a wine
business I was a marketer that happened
to understand how to invest in apps
because I thought they would be the
platforms that people would mark it on
so there was a little bit of a
self-awareness self-revelation kind of
going on for me and then I also knew
that I didn't know anything about the
biggest companies in the world that I
would done the small business thing that
I've done the Silicon Valley thing but
I'd never really understood what
coca-cola or Budweiser or BMW was
thinking and more importantly watching
from the outside
I was curious to why they were doing
what they were doing so I decided to
start the agency for two reasons one I
wanted to learn that world and two I
wanted to buy brands eventually so my
big ambition to be in this industry is
to buy nostalgic brands from CPG holding
companies
Wow yes a little bit of a different
angle yeah and so that all manifests as
you can tell in the form of creating a
very different shop first of all the
first 30 to 40 employees at vaynermedia
back in 2009 to 2011 had zero days of
agency experience so that was
interesting number two I'd built an
agency that did creative and media all
under one house which now seems to be a
conversation but was very foreign in
2009 when I started vaynermedia
something you know this is back to kind
of this strategy you know by being so
quiet you know we've been able to sneak
up on our size or scale you know we have
an office in London we're in a world
putting up Singapore this summer so
[Music]
agency yeah it's the biggest you know
it's funny I think when you walk around
here in the Harrier maybe you can add
some context it's interesting you have a
small group of people who are either our
clients which we have many of or people
that have worked with us or people that
have followed me on social that have a
bigger inkling and probably think we're
the next big thing and then you have an
enormous amount of people walking around
here that still have never heard of us
and it's kind of fun to be an enigma
yeah but it's all that but it's also fun
to now be at a maturity level where when
you're not only eight hundred people
when you're not only you know 150
million dollar revenue business and
you're an independent I mean I don't
know that stats on widening Kennedy but
we have to be the largest independent
agency in this industry besides widen
and yet by not over emphasizing on press
and awards in our first decade it hasn't
allowed the industry to get to know us
just yet
which which will be fun to you know be
involved in the industry a little bit
more in this next decade yeah possible
the revenues are gonna be a hundred
fifty million this year our our
headcount you just heard you know we
work with Pepsi and craft and chase and
yes hey I think you're right it's funny
that's such a showman I'm trying it's
funny that I'm more conservative on the
numbers I threw out than higher you'd
said you again to your auntie your
ambition was to buying nostalgic brands
have you done fulfilled that's where you
still heading towards is that your goal
still that's my goal the only thing I
was probably very wrong about when I
started the company ten years ago was
that the world would melt financially
five years ago five years later that was
my big thesis let me learn the industry
and then let me buy a brand and convert
my talent into the brand record that we
were gonna have a double-dip I did I
thought oh nine what the bailout was a
bad decision and and was putting a
bandaid and my intuition was that the
world was gonna melt my main thesis to
start the industry was Facebook Amazon
and Netflix were gonna win and the world
was gonna melt and I was right about
three of the four things yeah and the
fourth one has led to a very different
path I originally thought my agency
would be converted into a brand now it's
too big of a company and we enjoy it too
much that when I do buy a brand
eventually in three five seven nine
years then then then we're gonna still
keep the agency obviously and we're
gonna take some of the agency people
over to work on the businesses but I
just don't know when that will be and
I'm not an honest Lee I'm so worried
about building the agency that I'm not
overly I can't control that anyway so I
have to I have to be prepared but I
don't spend a whole lot of time trying
to figure out when
fascinating stuff yes it's definitely
testing yeah definitely interesting um I
also I also think it's double
interesting let me tell you why I'm not
sure but one of my things that I'm very
passionate about is to inspire a bigger
push towards independent agencies doing
different things yeah I think it would
be healthy for the business I don't
think I think I think the holding
companies are smart enough to know what
they need to worry about is the
consultancies yeah right they're gonna
worry about Accenture and others but I
do think for the health of the industry
having more significant independent
shops yeah I think would really matter
well I you see that a television I mean
the great of most of the great kind of
creative ideas in television and drama
and things a concert in the UK coming
out of a indie community they have more
freedom yeah you know I mean let's call
it what it is there's a there's a very
financially heavy infrastructure to this
creative field yeah I mean yeah that's
most you know when you look at all the
great creative shops that have worked
down there at the end if you follow all
the lines they're run by a CFO yeah
they're not run by a CCO yeah it's
changing that is true and I think it's
something that's worth having more of a
conversation about yeah do not beat
focus on it Witten like 300 words that
that we need a more progressive
conversation on volume of creative that
the industry needs to start not
demonizing quantity okay this notion
that quality is given up when you do a
quantity of creative there's a huge
misnomer and something that I think
would really benefit the industry and
most of all the brands most brands can't
make relevant creative because they're
not making enough creative to hit the
many different cohorts they need to be
talking to and so they end up making one
vanilla piece of video
don't don't speak someone just got the
Sun went down on your in your great
words I'm sorry they're not making
enough creative to hit all the cohorts
so just making one vanilla Pisa work
okay you know we we are - we are -
infatuated with reach and not enough
around relevance and if you don't make
seventy four hundred three thousand
pieces of meaningful content you can
never create actual relevance yeah okay
but if you go walk the streets right now
one of the worst words in the creative
community is volume and quantity that's
right and that needs to be cut we need
to have a more thoughtful conversation
around oh yeah they're bad words and
then they are yeah and so yeah funnily
enough over sojanet farmers love HBO
session yesterday where they were saying
oh how can you increase your output
without sort of losing the secret source
of HBO in a podium and how can you do
that without sacrifice now now that in
the form of a one-hour drama is a far
more interesting debate then trying to
communicate a toothpaste or a shampoo or
soda pop and the unconsumed right yeah
you know if I'm trying to sell know what
what what we know about long-form video
the theater movies television is some
shows are not meant for everybody we
have four people here and that's okay
that's fine I mean while we have this
audacious conversation that this
30-second spots supposed to make
everybody yeah inspire to buy that's
right Jay
HBO does do a lot of creative yeah they
have many different shows if HBO was a
creative agency they would have one show
yeah that's very cool here's another one
yeah here's one of they're important and
I know it's limited word and I'll you do
whatever you do I'm gonna give you one
more point that's a big for us okay we
are outrageously structure on actual
business results because my selfish
ambition is to own businesses all the
work we're doing is actually trying to
figure out how to drive businesses not
maximize our revenue and that has led us
to being more client centric okay
because I don't want to necessarily be
the most profitable I want to figure out
if my hypothesis is are true yeah
can I ask Eric whether yeah
I'm assuming but your early career in
wine and investing and Twitter you know
gave you the kind of finances to kind of
support your vision yes but you'll
appreciate this I take even more pride
actually in the fact that I know how to
run a business and we haven't raised any
capital and we've been able to pay the
payroll every single week and it hasn't
needed me to include any capital from my
personal self so I'm as you can tell by
my answer I I'm very proud that I'm an
actual business operator because a lot
of people you know run businesses that
don't make money because they're getting
VC capital and other people are are
running businesses that over tried to
extract profit at the expense of their
clients because they're publicly traded
so sure I feel like I have this nice
little middle zone yeah so you're gonna
stick your head above the parapet you've
come down here now yes and you good okay
hey guys I'm here
we're here and we're huge actually and
you've never heard of us and most of you
know and how are you going to go about
doing masking pen which you just say you
just slowly speak slower you yeah you
got it
I've been coming to camp at the muse and
you're not you're not involved in any
seminars I am I am I love speaking for
the Young Lions I just did a talk I'm
not sure and where they say um you know
I'm doing this with you like you know
we're but but the reality is this when
you're running a marathon you do
marathon behaviors yes to it and so the
answer to your question is patiently
which you know confuses people because I
have high energy as a human and so they
confused my natural DNA with my business
behavior yeah you know this is my
seventh year at camp
yes and so even though I'm high-energy
and confident and excited I'm also
respectful and I didn't want to scream
from the top of my lungs and you know
when I you know I've been patient I've
been learning now that we've got a
little bit of a real a business that you
know I think you know it I'm flattered
with like whoa and you know we you know
now that I understand the industry now
that I know we're having an independent
shop in ten years at this scale puts us
in the history of the industry not just
right now
the history of the industry how many
people have gone from 0 to 150 million
independently is very far and few
between I take a lot of pride in that
and I and I and I enjoy being part of
this industry even though we might be
taking a little bit of a different point
of view on it
this is fantastic I'm going to
unfortunately stop you there like you
always so much limited time so yeah it's
not such a celebrity